and another d4 okay let's go knight f6
and knight c3 so of course this is the
uh varasov you guys have seen me play
this
a bajillion times and of course if you
are not a french player if you're not a
perk player
then regardless of what you play against
d4 and c4 you should play d5 in this
position to prevent e4
that's what we're going to do
[Music]
here's f3 so that is some sort of a
weird cross between a black mardial and
a verison this is not a legitimate line
as far as i know
and
let's say that you're facing this you're
sitting there saying i've never seen
this move before but i understand what
the idea is right everybody should see
that clearly white wants to play e4
that's
that's pretty obvious
okay so
let's try to consult
the opening principles that we know and
use them to figure out what the best
move is well we know first of all that
when your opponent makes a move on the
side of the board or some sort of very
weakening move
very often it should be met with a
strike in the center because the strike
in the center opens up the center
exposes the weaknesses that have just
been created
so should we go e5 well let's consider
that for a second well e5 just d takes
e5 that doesn't seem to make sense are
there any other central
pawn breaks
that we know of um there is there's the
move c5 and that seems a lot more
sensible because if d takes c5 that
doesn't threaten anything we just saw
that
we can play d4 and that looks totally
overwhelming
now bishop f5 is also very much possible
to stop before
the only problem is that it doesn't
actually stop before
he can still play e4 sacrifice the pawn
and get a version of the blackmart dmr
gamut which if you remember i've kind of
already had i'll talk about this after
the game but bishop f5 e4
d
de4 fe4 94 queen f3
in fact this is important so let me show
you guys on the chess-based board
while the game goes on so d4 knight f6
what i'm talking about here is if we go
bishop f5 and he goes e4
takes takes takes boom goes the dynamite
queen f3 attacking
all of this stuff and this leads to
unpleasant consequences this is exactly
the kind of position that he wants so
let's not let him take the initiative
let's go c5 striking in the center one
of the things that makes this move very
strong is the fact that he can no longer
develop his knight to f3 so the pawn on
d4 already experiences a lot of trouble
hopefully that kind of makes sense
okay
yeah white is already in in in sort of
deep
deep uh yogurt here
yeah i mean e3 is probably what white
should do and just get a kind of crappy
position with that pawn on f3 but
you know generally speaking
people who play f3 and who want to be
you know some bishop e3 he's trying to
be creative
but he's digging himself
a much deeper hole
than you know
he started with
so what should we do should we take on
d4 is that is that what you wanted me to
do well taking on d4 plays into his
hands that's what
uh you know our opponent wants to allow
a cd4 bishop d4
and the bishop is centralized and that's
a little bit annoying so
a queen b6 is a little bit clunky
remember that if you can attack the d4
pawn with
a different piece with a lesser value
piece you should do that
e6 is a little bit too passive guys e6
doesn't create any threats knight c6 is
definitely the move because again if dc5
you should all see that d4 forks the
bishop and the knight this puts
tremendous strain on the d4 pawn thank
you jan
gifting to dragon b7 he drops his bishop
to f2 trying to get e3 in
but he's not going to make it uh the
game is already almost over what should
black do how should we should we take on
d4 now
well from the previous game you should
remember that one of the functions of
putting the knight on c6 is to be able
to play e5 at some point but should we
play e5 immediately no because that
allows him to take on e5 that's an out
we should first take the pawn drag the
bishop to d4
i think a lot of people would
instinctually want to take the bishop
there which is good which is good for
black black is better but we can do
better than that we can go e5 and start
steamrolling him with e5 and d4 very
intuitive play
very intuitive play
hopefully this all makes sense
too creative now d4 get the knight out
of there and already you should all be
looking at this diagonal now i think in
order to preserve chances
he should go knight b1 he shouldn't go
94 94 is the move a lot of i think
players in his range would play because
it's not it's the only non-retreating
move that's feasible
of course knight b5 loses a knight to
queen a5 check
but if you're white in such a position
of course you're almost lost
but you have to swallow your pride you
have to swallow your pride and the
reason knight b1 is better is because
then if we give him a check on b4 he's
going to be able to go pawn to c3
if he goes 94 and we trade the knights
off
and he does the c3 square is not as well
protected which means that a check along
this diagonal is going to be absolutely
devastating now let's try to be very
precise here
what is the most precise check this is a
tricky question
i encourage people to think about this
don't rush
what is the most instructive or sorry
the most
precise
accurate check
well lauren i i don't know if you would
never make such mistakes
maybe you would make different mistakes
so
i'm tricking some of you
clearly we have two checks queen a5 and
bishop b4 now if you were to use my rule
right and say well i want to give a
check with a piece of the lowest value
then you would go bishop b4 check it
also seems very natural but let's
calculate specifically
bishop before check he has to go c3
okay we play d takes e3
now look at that position for a second
he can take the queen
and what that allows him to do is to
castle long
with or without check and avoid a
devastating discovery
by playing queen a5 we are getting rid
of the queen standoff which does not
permit him
to get his king to safety he is going to
have to move his queen to do that and
his queen cannot move away with check
anymore
if he goes queen d2
then of course then we go bishop b4 and
we win the game
so this is a purely concrete
consideration
that's what chess is all about at this
level it's the ability to realize oh
here i have to calculate specifically if
you're on the cusp of winning the game
then you should definitely take some
time
uh to make sure you're calculating
because if you rely too much on general
principles
that's exactly how you miss these
winning chances
well if b4 then we just played bishop
takes before check with checkmate to
follow soon after
no b4 bishop takes before don't take
with the queen because then he plays
queen d2
yeah we're crushing
we're totally crushing here this the
game is over
and um
this this was just too creative bishop
e3
yep you're welcome this was just you
know
he uh shot himself in the foot with that
move
queen d2
bishop before now he's got to go c3 then
we take on c3
this is all super straightforward
he has a choice between moving his queen
then we take on b2 with mate or if he
takes then we take with a bishop and we
win his queen
yeah this is over
game is over red rover
yeah i mean this was
quite straightforward
why doesn't a 1700 rated player well
see what exactly is it that he missed
he got dragged into this
already after d4 he was getting
desperate so
i wouldn't give him too much flack for
this
when you get faced with a position
that's this difficult you kind of often
times collapse
and he resigns yeah
yeah i don't know why you played f3 he
might have confused something again
we've all had games where we make
you know maybe this has worked out for
him in the past because here's the thing
uh need lest i remind you a lot of you
guys were proposing bishop f5 and if you
play bishop f5 then f3 is pretty much
justified so
let's not um
you know judge white too harshly for
this move maybe it was working out for
him
again if bishop f5 then he transposes
into a variation of the black martial so
e4 takes takes knight e4 now this bishop
is undefended he can hit the bishop with
queen f3
and i don't know what to make of this
position i mean we can play knight d6
guarding both b7 and f5
but uh you know this is the kind of
position that a player like him would
want
rapid development castles quickly
uh hard for us to complete our
development in a timely fashion
uh but but this i would have never
thought of c5 so
let's
take a deep dive for a second figure how
can you find a move like c5 well i think
now
a lot of you guys will be looking for
this move
but first c5 is a typical move in any
uh d4 d5 opening right it's not like oh
this is some sort of a new concept c5 is
a very natural move for both sides
uh and when white plays knight c3 the
entire reason that this move is
considered inaccurate
is because it blocks the c pawn and so
c5 is a way of exploiting
one of the drawbacks of knight c3
and
you know yeah if you look at a lot of
games you'll you'll find this to be to
be the case
okay so
the other thing is that
yeah so the other thing is that by
playing f3 he
uh he is poorly equipped to protect the
d4 pawn especially now because knight f3
is no longer possible
so c5
now he should have played e3 that was uh
the lesser evil and white's position
remains uh playable knight c6 you know
bishop b5 you just gotta get your pieces
out like this white is much worse
and we would have probably played this
you know e6 bishop b7 castle is nothing
special he's just got a ton of
weaknesses here on the king side
but um
bishop e3 was the decisive mistake
knight c6
now obviously my my instinct is always
to retain the the tension so
instinctually i don't like this move and
i also don't like it concretely it helps
him helps him get the bishop out get the
e pawn rolling
so we go knight c6 putting more pressure
on d4 if he takes it we fork him
we've got two defenders on the pawn so
this is very much possible
the point of c5 is very yeah it is to
destabilize the d4 pawn it is
you know entirely the same as as you
know the point of the king's game but
you're destabilizing a central pawn
uh so that you enhance your control of
the center
that's the skeleton idea here
okay so bishop b3 knight c6
bishop f2 takes takes e5 e4
and i think the last
you know idea would have been to go
knight b1 as miserable as this looks
because again if we give a check on b4
or on a5 he goes c3 and he's still
uh he's still surviving here
so
what would black do who can propose a
good move in this position
and one good way of approaching this is
to ask yourself
how is white going to untangle his
pieces and there's really only one way
of doing so white has to push the epon
in order to get the bishop out there's
just no other way
so there is a very nice prophylactic
move
to prevent him from pushing the e-pawn
there's a couple of moves actually
there's three at least you can go knight
to d5
and e4 on fassant for example
you can go i would say the simplest is
to play bishop c5 because you're also
developing a piece or queen b6 is also
very nice in this case because you're
attacking b2 and you're clamping down on
the e3 square and of course white is
losing here i mean look at how miserable
his position is but
you know why can climb out of this so
you know if you're getting crushed like
this and you're white
you sometimes have to say all right well
my position is terrible but i'm going to
swallow my pride i'm going to make some
moves that look
incredibly nasty but at least they're
going to help me stay in the game
and the same goes for
you know what my old coach gm gregory
kaidanov called saying sorry which is
making a move realizing it's bad and
then just bringing the piece back to
where it came from which is something
that a lot of players struggle with
tremendously
knight e4 takes takes and finally
if bishop before check
c3
dc3
queen takes the eight check and again it
doesn't matter what we take the queen
with taking with the king only throws
more oil onto the fire because he
castles now with check
but um if knight takes d8
still he castles and
black is dominating or up a pawn but
that's
all we've gained from this and white
plays on
all right
so queen a5 check queen d2 bishop before
if he goes c3 dc3 is totally crushing he
cannot prevent a discovered
check or a discovered capture
and if he takes then we take
we take
and we checkmate him on b4
so
that's basically game over any questions
about this game
and again nobody should be afraid to ask
questions
i'm happy to repeat stuff always more
than happy to do it
don't feel like you're holding anybody
anybody um up
okay
yeah i don't know why he chose the setup
i can't really answer that
well
comparing to the king's indian i mean
there is no way to play the king's
indian against knight c3 that's a mis if
you play g6 you allow e4 and this is not
the king's indian this is now the perk
yeah so the in the jaba london
c5 is a legitimate line
and after e3
if you watch my blitz games you will
find that people go a6 here and there's
a very good reason for that if you go
knight c6 there's a very common trap
i've caught a lot of gms in this trap
knight b5 and all of a sudden it's
incredibly hard to defend the c7 square
so you're right
black should play a6 in the juba london
um
what if white plays e4 after c5
okay
well if he plays e4 i think we just take
on e4
i agree e4 would probably be his best
move
and maybe dc something like this go into
some sort of an end game which is
miserable for white
but maybe a little bit more playable
than bishop e3 so
uh you know we just go bishop d7 and
castle white is super passive here
uh that's what we would have done
what happens if he took c5 so if he took
c5 we've successfully displaced the pawn
and i would have probably gone d4
attacking the night
knight b5 queen a5 check wins the night
and um thank you luxor i really
appreciate it and if he goes 94 for
example we can take knight c6 e5 bishop
c5 this is totally just horrible
is e6 inaccurate instead of c5
um
yes e6 is too slow because basically
you're almost transposing into some sort
of a french
where yes white has played f3 that's
sub-optimal but why voluntarily closed
down the bishop and stuff right c5 is
just far more ambitious
all right
for beginners i think queen's gamma
decline is probably the best
it's just more solid
alright guys just because everybody's so
generous and i'm getting
a lot of bribes
let's play one more
for the folks at home
yeah but people i mean
this opening was really shoddy by our
opponents so usually we're not winning
games that fast
what's up you kyo okay
let's go
okay d4
and finally we got white can you believe
it
we got white
okay so we're going to play mainline
d4c4
okay so this is the nimzo indian and
what do i recommend
against the nimzo well there's three
main systems that
white has and all of them are legitimate
we can play into the nimzo indian with
knight c3 knight c3 bishop b4 is the
nimzo indian he can also go d5 and
transpose into the queen's gambit
knight f3 is a gateway into the queen's
indian into the ragazin or to the
queen's gambit
and the most like independent line is to
go g3 that is called the catalan
the catalan is a very positional opening
it's incredibly reputable and popular at
the highest levels but you know the most
positionally rich move is to go into the
nimzo let's go into the dim zone go
knights yeah he goes c5 so he plays the
binoni thank you t paige for the three
months he plays the benoni
and this is one of the several ways to
reach the benoni you can also play c5 in
this position and
uh transpose after knight c3 so uh he
goes c5 let's go into mainline bononi
with d5
he takes him and goes d6
okay
he goes d6 immediately
now that is a bit inaccurate that's a
little bit passive it's not
terrible but it's passive
how should white expand in the center
what's the typical binoni move here of
course it's to play e4
and the reason that d6 is inaccurate is
because after e takes d5
you should always use the process of
comparison comparing often yields wisdom
about the position that otherwise you
might not have attained
okay
what's the difference well here we can
play he takes d5 and we can maintain the
the the symmetry of the pawn structure
uh and his position is tremendously
cramped now
given that he's probably going to take
on d5 where do we want to put this
bishop what would be a good forward
thinking square for this bishop
given that he's probably going to play e
takes d5 and if he doesn't it still
would be good on that square i love to
put the bishop on d3 here
okay knight d7
now there's no need for us to take i
don't think that trade is particularly
beneficial for white
um
we have a couple of ways that we could
that we could um
you know uh set up our pieces
a very ambitious approach would be to
play f4 and get the pawn i don't like
that move i don't really recommend it in
the sense of playing positionally no
need to reinvent the wheel let's develop
the knight okay again very unoriginal
but solid his position is just so
cramped
and we're going to try to squeeze the
life out of him here which is a way of
playing that i think some of you uh
might use a little bit of help with
okay so knight g4 i i assume he's trying
to get a knight to e5 which is totally
not dangerous and we shouldn't try to go
out of our way to stop him why because
if you just calculate a little bit
further down the road let's say we
castle
which is what we're going to do he's
probably going to go 95 or this knight
to e5
uh and you know
this there's a misconception associated
with pieces that are in the center i've
talked about this before you can't
assume that a piece in the center is
good just because it's in the center
uh and one of the litmus tests is well
how easy is is it to chase that piece
away and you should see that well we're
going to be able to play f4 at some
point so we should definitely take the
knight
and then we should drop the bishop back
and then we should play f4 this knight
is not going to hold on to e5 right so
it's it's good for a couple of moves
but then we're gonna hit it with f4 now
we need to be careful
don't just automatically drop the bishop
to c2 that would blunder the pawn let's
go bishop e2 we gotta be precise
and then we're gonna hit him with a nice
little f4
with tempo
and now that we're fully developed f4 is
a little bit less
risky
hope that makes sense
all right bishop f6
well um
i don't see a reason
not to play f4
let's go
uh well i've talked about that before
about making the king more vulnerable
and the bottom line is that among the
three
pawns pushing the f-pawn is the most
innocuous because you're not actually
destroying the pawn shell around the
king you still have your g and h ones so
remember that you can always tuck your
king on h1 and the king is still going
to be relatively safe so
i think it's important to uncouple all
three of those pawn wait i mean making a
move like g4 is infinitely more
weakening that doesn't mean you never
want to make it there are situations
when you push all three of your pawns in
front of your king but i you know i hope
that makes sense
okay so this is a very rich position
the simplest move is to go bishop e3 we
can complete our development we don't
care about him taking and doubling our
pawns that's that's just not that
important we definitely want him to do
that
and uh we also have some interesting
stuff going on here with a move like e5
trying to sacrifice the pawn but i don't
need i don't see a reason to reinvent
the wheel let's just go bishop e3
and part of playing positionally having
a positional style is knowing
when simplicity is is required
all grandmasters uh no matter if it's
mike mikeltal
you know or anybody you associate with
an attacking style
you can become truly good without
knowing when to play uh with simplicity
and
that is sometimes a far more difficult
skill to acquire than you know
understanding when a fancy move is
required because we all like to find
fancy moves and sacrifices but this kind
of very simple play
uh you know ornery
just develop your pieces kind of meat
and potato style
can be hard for players who are looking
for interesting games and stuff and yet
sometimes you just have to bite the
bullet and play like that okay so here
the situation has changed a little bit
how should we understand this position
well
um
whenever there exists a source of
central tension there are pawns that are
in a standoff
you have an obligation
on every move to spend a couple of
seconds considering whether you want to
be the one to release the tension right
that's just something that you want to
do because who knows maybe the
circumstances change in one move you
didn't want to release the tension but
all of a sudden again things have
changed and now you do
so
hint hint wink
i think this is a situation where now we
want to take on e6 why
because he if he takes with the bishop
sorry if he takes with a bishop he gets
forked f5
could somebody explain to me why the
trade benefits us now now that we've
completed our development
what is it about the position
uh that benefits us
in the event of defe
i will give you guys a hint it it
enables us to accomplish a very
straightforward plan
so what's what physically happens well
the d
file is open
what exists on the d file there's a weak
backward d6 bond
and
connect two and two together we have a
weak d6 pawn we have an open d file what
plan
literally begs to be played well queen
b2 rook d1 look at how nicely this
coordinates all of white's pieces
we okay so
i just i just explain all that for like
10 minutes any minute this is a fork
um yeah let's just castle
but uh it's like ernest hemingway's
iceberg theory you know
this is exactly i think there's a good
analogy to be made and i found this to
be the case when you think very deeply
so just to paraphrase um as far as i
remember the iceberg theory
i think it was advanced by hemingway it
basically says
90 percent of
your character a character that appears
in a work of fiction
should not make it uh to the surface of
the book it should be behind the scenes
because the ten percent that will appear
will be so deeply written that you need
those 90
of character development behind the
scenes to be able to write a deep book
and i think that
a similar thing goes here when you think
very deeply about your moves even if
you feel like it's a sunk cost like your
opponent didn't go into it
your understanding of the position is
still
deep
uh to where
first of all you've just gotten better
at whatever type of thinking you did and
you know it might pay off later he also
blunders the pawn on d6 so it did pay
off in the end
all right
hello
so we want to go e5 and just crush him
down the f file everything is falling
rook 81 is is coming
yeah that's some good writing advice
that i was given as well so a little bit
of a bonus speed run bonus okay let's go
rook d1 just bring the rook into the
game this game is over
i'm quite surprised that he blundered in
that way but
perhaps he was getting a little bit
dejected by his position
okay
yeah after this game i'm gonna get going
guys
it's already pretty late
it's been five hours that's pretty cool
time has flown by
yeah of course my pleasure
no worries
okay rook f7
okay so we can't let him escape here how
should we continue
how should we continue
yeah so e5 seems very natural here e5
just crushing him down every file every
avenue
uh you can almost play these moves
you know by intuition
there isn't anything to oh well that's a
great reason you're forgiven
you are very much forgiven
okay he resigns
one second
all right guys so um
it it it is you know because foreign
another piece it does so
this was a pretty straightforward game
um the main line benoni is is edc d6
wait let me open up another instance of
the game
okay
so uh the mainline benoni is is is d5 ed
cd d6
you know we'll get a chance to talk
about it i don't want to talk about it
now because i'm sure somebody will play
it against me
yeah so edc ed
just very very cramped position for
black
and i don't think he did anything
terribly wrong
up until the very end i mean i think he
was playing fine
and it's one of those things right after
c6 we would have gone queen d2
then we would have gone rook a to d1
that pawn on d6 is going to be
tremendously weak i definitely want to
talk about the benoni at some point but
not now and we're definitely much better
here we can also go knight b5 later
uh so this is just you know it just
played two passively here but but he
could have held on in this way
uh so
in any case
uh we're going to pause for today guys
it's it's been five hours i'm exhausted
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to bed
i will definitely be back tomorrow
evening probably late evening
and um
yeah so
okay uh it was a great stream
um
i had a lot of fun today
um
thank you for hanging out
uh and uh i'll see you guys tomorrow for
more blitz and more speedrun i really
appreciate
the support all of the subs
it helps me a lot
so thanks everybody everybody who subs
to the youtube
you're awesome as well
um
and uh that's just
great stuff thank you 20 bucks and we
got jared hill 2257.
you're amazing donny i'm a beginner
player who was practicing chess for
hours a day without improving
but your videos helped me go from 900 to
1400 in just a few months i can't thank
you enough is your videos which is gold
for people like well that's very sweet
very very sweet i'm sure you also the
work you did also paid off tremendously
so
you know give yourself some credit but i
really appreciate that
that that means the world to me so
thanks guys
we will raid um who should we raid
we're going to raid uh well let's rate
chess bro let's do our traditional late
night chess bar raid
um
have a good time of the month take care
everybody
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]